hey how you doing dr. Wallace very fine
shirt thank you how can we help you
okay um back when I was about in my
teens I would say 14 15 years old I was
wrestling with some some friends and I
got my permanent tooth knocked loose and
it was it's my front front too at the
right side got knocked loose and it took
it took a few weeks but it healed up and
hardened again
so my question the dentist recommends
won't let me say this to thee
the tooth is a little black on the
inside but on the outside looking at it
from the outside it's only like this
color at the top a little bit and I get
a little sensitivity there when you say
by the top you mean at the gum level or
at the edge of the tooth yes
yep the gum level is slightly discolored
there okay I'm getting a little bit of
sensitivity like electric shocks there
it can hang once a week twice a week and
stops okay hang on how much you weigh
Kevin how much you weigh Kevin I'm about
168 and I'm five nine okay there's about
right okay do you have any other issues
you have any ringing in the ears or ever
feel like you have motion problems
motion sickness or some maybe even some
nausea anything like that uh it's funny
it's funny say that recently for the
past few weeks I have had a little of
that I couldn't explain what it was but
it's very slight I've been telling my
wife and I don't know what that's about
but yes it's okay it kind of goes along
with what you're talking about Charmaine
what's going on here with Kevin what's
gonna cause ringing in the ears and
Wallach Ike's trying to go high extreme
osteoporosis of what what part of the
body the bones the the joins the head
the skull let's go yeah and of course
when you squeeze the best uvular
branches the aged granular if you get
this sort of motion sickness kind of
thing like you know the room is moving
around you'll get a sort of an imbalance
problem here you might even get ringing
in the ears if you're also squeezing the
auditory branch of the external nerve
and what happens is when you have
osteoporosis of the skull you can get
that when you're three years old you can
be born with it looking but what happens
is there's 12 cranial nerves on each
side of the head they all go through a
tunnel to the outside where they do
things if you're squeezing the seventh
cranial nerve the facial nerve you get
Bell's palsy if you're squeezing the
fifth cranial nerve you try general
neuralgia if you're squeezing the ninth
cranial nerve you get changing your
voice you may even lose your voice for a
while you know you remember Mel and yeah
uh-huh yeah yeah okay and of course you
squeeze the ninth cranial nerves the
glossopharyngeal nerve you can lose your
voice and then have a voice problem and
so is your body weight what would you
get what are you what would you give
Kevin Charmaine to deal with his problem
of osteoporosis in the skull muscles got
a problem 168 pounds well for all his
issues at his weight I would give him
two healthy bone and joint packs okay
and how many gluco gel would you make
him take I would give him 20 a day to
start out and he can cut it back when he
gets better okay and what would you do
to make sure he gets enough sunshine so
all the minerals work vitamin d3 okay to
healthy bone and joint packs 15 gluco
gel a day you can throw in as charge
says two bottles of the vitamin d3 a day
so you a month give me two bucks a month
sitting take three of those vitamin d3
capsules twice a day and because you've
got the healthy bone and joint pack what
would you have him do is some of that cm
cream that comes along with that I'd get
some trauma oil and add to it and put it
in the ear a little bit with a q-tip and
be careful yeah don't don't puncture
your eardrum but you do it don't anybody
else do it the whole idea here is in the
down in the air with a q-tip and also a
finger full of the Sam cream behind the
ear where the ear meets the the scalp on
your neck and your head
and that way you're going to relieve
some of the inflammation around the root
of that H cranial nerve and relieve
symptoms I mean I've had you know people
who have that problem for 23 years in
ten minutes that was gone when you put
the same cream down in the air and
behind the ear but it will kind of
gradually come back in three hours is
that
Tech wears off but after two or three
months on the healthy bone and joint
pack which is designed to support and
promote maintance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
bone itself as the body repairs itself
need to use that cm cream and the trauma
oil is significant reduced or eliminated
but this is all a simple problem of a
osteoporosis of the skull but of course
is happening all over the body the
beautiful thing about these nutritional
programs is it works on the entire body
even though you have major symptoms in
your skull it works every place else you
don't yet have symptoms and of course
some of the time for instance Kevin you
turn your head to the left to put your
chin on your left shoulder or put your
chin on your right shoulder to the right
you get grinding in your neck this is
some cracking in my neck you
there you go it'll all go away it was
call every two weeks we'll walk you
through this brother